>> So, if we think about the equation that
we were doing before, which was you know, the sum
of all these gammas times some R max. We
can basically take out the R max and what we
end up with is something that looks like that,
right? You're summing together a bunch of gammas and then
multiplying the result by R max. So what does that
acutally look like? Well that looks like this. Gamma to
the zero, plus gamma to the one, plus gamma squared, plus dot dot
dot dot. Eventually multiplied by R max.
Right? So let's call this x, okay?
>> Does x include the R max or not?
>> No. So we'll just call the little sequence of,
it's going to turn out not to matter. Let's just call
the sequence of gammas we're adding together, let's just call that x.
>> Good.
>> Well, if you look at it, this is actually recursive. Right? Because this
is an infinite sequence, if you sort of shifted it one over in time, you
would end up with just the repeated sequence again. All right? Which means that
we can write x in terms of itself. x equals gamma zero plus gamma times X.
>> I
see, so it's shifted over, but then you have to multiply
it again by gamma, to get up to gamma one, gamma two.
>> Right, exactly. So, so, this is just,
you know, it's just math, that's just all
it is. so, we can try to solve for x and figure out what x is, right?
>> Cool.
>> So, what is x? Well, we can subtract from both sides and so
we end up with like, something like x minus gamma x equals gamma 0. Right?
>> Seems
like we can stop writing gamma 0. Isn't that just one?
>> Yes, but I've already, I've gone too
far, Michael. I've alrea, I've already written gamma 0.
>> Alright. [LAUGH]
>> so, this becomes x times 1 minus gamma equals gamma 0, or as Michael so
astutely points out, 1. [LAUGH]. Alright. Which means what? It means that.
>> So then we divide by 1 minus gamma.
>> a is 1 over 1 minus gamma.
>> Neat.
>> And that,
of course, we are going to multiply by R max.
>> To get the formula that we had. That's, yeah, that's nifty.
>> Yeah, there we go. So, why do we do this? Well, because you like
stuff like this and it points out something
very simple, which is that geometry is easy.
>> [LAUGH] I don't think that's the
kind of geometry that people usually think of.
>> Well, they should be thinking of this kind of geometry.
So geometry is easy. And by doing a little cute algebra,
we can derive ridiculous equations that turn out to help
us deal with go an infinite distance in finite time.
>> [LAUGH]
I don't think that's what they're doing, but okay.
>> [LAUGH] So, let's think of this as warmup for what I actually wanted to
show you, which is going to turn out to be a whole lot of math. Okay?
>> Alright, let's, let's go for it.
>> Alright, let's do that.